do you think we're color-coordinated no
we called each other they don't know or
I just talked you outside your house you
are hilarious
oh you're nice it's wrong I just get
lost and I go make a joke until you know
what you're doing if you know how much I
hear your name and Idol Oh everyone says
I want to be like Kelly I want to be
like what are you talking and I'm saying
so I'm just telling you that's how
amazing were these educators I mean a
Rinat floor I thought it was so were you
ever touch my like a teacher or coach or
anything I was touched by a teacher
every day my mother how much was an
elementary school principal it's so
funny you know when you live with the
teacher mm-hmm you're first of all
you're broke everything is going to be
perfect you understand me
hated red pins and she was an English
she was an English instructor hmm so I
would always say things like mom can I
do so-and-so she says I don't know can
you
I was tortured so let's talk Stevie
Wonder because I know you're my friends
do y'all like literally hang out all the
time and like Stevie is probably I'm
gonna tell you something I've been
spinning my whole life with him thinking
he can see I know he can see no he can
see listen the story I tell this the
funniest I went to his house he says
want to hear a new song I've got it in
the car come on go with me we go out to
the car he says do you sit on the
passenger side I'll sit on the driver's
side he goes in he cranks the car up he
puts the tape in right and then he does
this and it starts driving back down the
driveway no sir and I scream said Stevie
what are you doing
and he said got you didn't
[Laughter]
I hate to get around it because every
time I would get around and I would not
want to give a phrase to him because
he'll write a song with it if I say how
are you doing Steve how you do I'll see
you later see you later fragrance
collection which comes in two scents one
for men and another for women but they
are both called
hello I love this what made you want to
do this well you know what it is I'm a
songwriter what can I do and creativity
is like on my thing that's just my list
and so when I thought about it for a
moment I said okay what else can I do to
play around with some ideas of and the
fragrance came up like number one
because it's just a series of get this
now they're called notes so if you say
grapefruit or amber or you know jasmine
or whatever they're called notes and so
when you arrange the notes properly the
the since the smell all of a sudden you
can come up with your own smell oh my
god I went from there to crazy because
now I see use it in music there's only
12 notes in fragrance forget about it
so the men's fragrance is fantastic
because I don't want to smell like this
guy because I'm a little Metro as we say
yes I'm okay with that yeah we don't
want to be too rugged comfortable in
your skin but the word is clean clean
and fresh opposed to heavy and weighted
when people bathe in it oh my god oh my
god and to the ladies perfume I must
tell you you want to be able to put it
on and just be it mixes with your scent
so you're not feeling like you just took
a shower yeah and what's with your body
chemistry and the thing about it is once
I've actually figured out that I found
my sins yeah for male and female I
really got excited I've never heard
anyone describe perfumer cologne like
that like obviously there are different
notes yeah something suppose like
Jasmine smells like that's so
interesting I've never thought
like that I love it so pick up 99 copies
of this no but is it's it's really very
special but you have an Instagram
account which I think it's hard for me
to stand social media and people like
you to be active but I always feel like
a tool but you're hilarious it's for
your dogs it's like a tiny dog is my dog
Sylvester Sylvester Sylvester and so
what we did was the best it became a
star to the point where he's only this
big by this big oh my god and so he
thinks he's a full-grown pit bull and so
what we do is we just didn't tell him so
we hold him up here so as long as he's
up here it's and then he put him on the
floor and he has nervous breakdown but
but what I love about him is he's so
adorable
he and seeing a grown man like a big
tall guy with a tiny dog that's the door
that's adorable
my dog Henry literally if my even my
children not even just dogs
he Bruins have been gets in between me
and my children is so jealous dogs are
so jealous well they become a part of
your personality so you understand they
want attention oh well I do like not
yeah
no we're not looking for attention are
we and then you have your kid who's
competing with that and then the dogs
going enough of this give me my treat
another thing I wanted to say is you
actually had a residency at Planet
Hollywood right and I'm about to have
one so did you love it you're gonna love
it okay I'm a little nervous just cuz
it's a drag no no no no no forget about
anything you've ever heard about that
the stereotype of that the beauty of it
is you play the show and you go home at
night yeah and the same place and it's
the same listen you have to understand
when we do a world tour
it's literally fly play fly play
occasionally you'll sleep Planet
Hollywood it's going to be so great for
you because it's the crowd is adorable
number one anything you say or do
they're gonna you're
yes you don't say so you have to
understand what makes it so wonderful as
we talk to them we don't just sing we
interact with part of their part of the
show I mean cuz if you just wanted the
music you could just close your eyes and
imagine the show unless you're going to
love it you're going to love I'm excited
yeah I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this